the pot sir get ready pot sir has given
me beating after beating on stream I
don't know if we've played just off
stream at all but he's given me many a
runs for my money
Wow is it tornado land here or something
oh I don't know if you'd hear that in
the background it's a little scary
they're scary d4 d5 let's go because
this guy moves quick oh man and by the
way if some reason Comcast kills me if I
fall for the comcast gambit again
I'll go to my trusty little phone and
send out a tweet Twitter at chest
network so you could check that out and
if it says I've been hit with the
Comcast gambit you'll know the scoop
okay what does one do Queeny - I gotta
get something different I don't like
playing against this black setup in fact
I'm gonna stop playing against ok let's
let's do this maybe yeah let's do that
in-betweener ok I thought there might be
the possibility of Bishop takes there
but we're not having that Wow
it's pretty loud here it's pretty loud
ok ok ok
wow it's pretty nuts I don't know if you
could hear that it is pretty loud wow
it's pretty loud so if I lose I'm being
distracted so there's my excuse there's
my excuse so what about a five and then
night here it seems pretty good b5 in
the night there let's give that a whirl
Wow
yeah if you're not hearing it turn up
your turn up your volume you'll be
hearing that this is the tornado gambit
right here
the hurricane gambit I should say that
came Knight e4 I'm looking at this
square this is the main point also
another main point is since with E 5 I
have a space advantage I want to keep
more pieces on the board let's keep
those pieces around no this Bishop is
great this Knight it's night
what is the knight up to let's do that I
don't know what why exactly but I'm
gonna give it a shot and maybe just rip
d1 like bolstering my Center I I don't
well this is the main thing action I
don't want this night to pivot on b6 I
don't want that night to pivot on b6 so
that's that's what's prompting a5 in
other words and let's let's build my
Center it's got to be a little bit scary
for black to be opposite this rook right
this bishop by the way it just simply
doesn't know what it wants to do it
doesn't know what it wants to do and
maybe I want to try for h3 and g4 I I
was for a second and this was a couple
of moves ago before I did a5 and rook d1
I was thinking g3 but something like
Bishop h5 made me cringe made me cringe
now that move I think is really good I
think it's really good
they play there though I know what the a
file to open up I'm not in a position to
have these rooks
in tension with one of not with one
another this bishop is a great piece and
I hear and I think we're gonna be seeing
c5 very soon I should probably make yeah
c5 is on the agenda here it's on the
agenda okay well I wonder
I wonder if this night is such a pain I
gotta work around this guy I have to
keep working around him oh wait a second
why wasn't I thinking this the whole
time what's the matter with me
Oh bishop here's no good I'm glad I
didn't think of that Bishop takes Knight
and guess it loses a piece team white
okay it's time to regroup time to
regroup what does one do the time is
ticking it's rainy it's windy h3h3
Knight here that power will be picked
off before you know it you know it'll be
a happening like that okay I don't know
if this is it but I'm gonna do it and
let's see anything better okay
I don't see anything better than to just
do that and maybe I could play Bishop e5
c5 Bishop b5 Annoying pin chop okay
let's do this right now
chop chop incoming knight c6 could be
very disruptive let's see if that
happens let's see if it happens I think
this this has to be an annoying Bishop
right
there's no way white could say to
themselves you know I feel really
comfortable about my knight not being
able to move without the loss of
material do you think that Knight is
saying that right now so and can the
bishop the and the other thing the
question is is this Bishop going to be
kicked away anytime soon okay
flight squared time might as well try
that flight square the knight is now
free to move and actually maybe I should
have been doing something else okay well
this is gonna get very complicated it's
going to get very very complicated yep I
could see right now
you can see right now complications
coming up let's try it
Knight takes e see it takes ease that
we're gonna be seeing here okay my
computer is going a bit nuts right now
I don't like the sound of it I'm having
to check some things out right now and
not even look at the board
all righty then
this is tough that is a fantastic move
and
I'm in trouble I am in trouble here I'm
very scared for my computer actually
more so than my physician okay it's uh
it's it's doing better I don't know what
just happened it was going crazy okay
time time is even and I'm in a nasty pen
oh I could take that bishop what am i
doing
just take the bishop what is it matter
with you
why do we see I could be taking that
okay whatever and now I take the knight
with my queen okay and now after the
smoke has cleared who stands better
because this is a giant mess it's a
giant mess Queen takes pawn and
everything is flow now that is something
I did not expect Knight takes pawn or um
Bishop here
I think Bishop there's good think that
that might have been missed
maybe our Bishop here wait a second the
Queen was close to cooked ah bishop
right here would have been awesome this
should be five I didn't even consider it
okay this is um mmm Queens off the board
at least get the Queens off the board
Queens off
okay know what's happening here what is
going on night has to take you can't
allow me that past a pond there's no way
right let's go here it's tucked in
pretty good watch over this square and
Bishop right here this Bishop absolutely
wants to be on this square eyeing two
pawns right here this one being a very
important one and now that here we go
we're gonna have more trades and there's
Oh actually let's just watch over this
guy for just a hair just a second and
this pile up on this time gotta go quick
and now let's push this rook away and
grab that night hopefully chase him away
chase him away watch over that and then
I could do a pawn push Bishop back or
something okay let's do this let's back
up I want I want to UM why'd I do that
hon push rook trade
okay now Oh move move move move move
okay now it's clear clear the coast is
clear
Bishop blocks okay now it's a queen time
that on time time time let's get my king
up no stalemate ah what no way it's
stalemate no matter what I do
oh oh
itself still me ah there was nothing I
could do you see that final position
that was wicked I think I've played a
lot of blitz games and I don't think
I've ever gotten into position where no
matter what I did on my next move it
didn't matter
Wow look at that
my king move was stupid myself stalemate
King their King h3 was foolish but I
simply didn't I didn't see it
she's six no matter what I do I move my
king so what stalemate I move my rook so
what stalemate ah that's cool
I like that finished good game good game
that was a that was also a very
interesting middle game very very
interesting middle game let me back up
let's back this one up very cool what a
save
what a saved man okay so this is pretty
intense
I wonder if um I think black is better
here I wonder a great deal about the
move a five not even allowing me to play
a five myself I think maybe that is uh
yeah I think that is maybe yeah an
improvement I was fumbling with that how
easy was that to say I think a five
might be an improvement just to say you
know uh okay what do you got next what
do you got going on next because I
stopped your idea of pressing forward
placing upon and on my side stopping
Knight b6 stuff no a5 you clamp down on
b4 this Knight Bishop you know you could
pivot about on this square as long as
you want it's under your control so I
think that that's a nice positional move
to be considering you know when you
weigh the two moves whether if these
happen to be candid moves a5 Bishop e7
this is a move I can't stop this is a
move I can stop so try and get that one
in first in other words to switch the
move order but it got pretty nuts right
here I really went into a think tank
right here I don't know I I thought I
was ready to like move my move my bishop
back c1 d1 and then
okay I could take the bishop and I think
this all this sequence of moves actually
ends up benefiting me so I think there
was something before this I don't know
about I don't know about capturing maybe
black does well to just keep the tension
still how about how about Queen did see
seven and then rip to d8 in fact in this
position instead of rip there how about
Queen c7 rook to d8 I think that's the
way to go I don't know if you really
need your your knight to move I'm the
very next turn so that's another thing
to be looking into and on my end I'm
sure there's other things prior to it
but as was pointed out oh this uh yeah
actually Bishop to a5 in response to
that Queen b6 that would have been
pretty good Bishop here and then the
Queen s to come back we have the Queen's
come off or something maybe not maybe
it's Tellarite the move I played but
definitely towards the endgame what's
the correct way to win this I was up a
rook I couldn't do I'm not gonna find
that one's painful
how about this just push up on here
what's the matter with you what is the
matter with you pushed boom boom push me
man I just I didn't I just had to move
too because my clock was at 3.2 okay
good game that was fun interesting way
to have that one end cool let's close